[Musique]
maxime bernier est né en 1963 à saint
georges de beauce
il est le fils de gilles bernier qui a
été longtemps député progressiste
conservateur de beauce maxime bernier
est diplômé en commerce et en droit il a
fait ses premiers pas en politique au
sein du cabinet du ministre des finances
du québec bernard landry
à la fin des années 90 après un passage
dans le secteur privé maxime bernier est
élu député de beauce en 2006 avec la
plus importante majorité pour un député
conservateur à l'extérieur de l'alberta
il devient ministre de l'industrie sous
stephen a puis ministre des affaires
étrangères il doit démissionner avec
fracas 2008 après laffaire julie
couillard en 2017
ils perdent de justesse la course à la
direction du parti conservateur
un an plus tard il claque la porte du
parti pour d'abord siéger comme
indépendant et ensuite fondu le parti
populaire du canada
[Musique]